that quitting acting was hugely
instrumental like i needed that for my
mental health and i needed that for my
own self growth and my own relationship
with myself i couldn't keep literally
being people that other people write and
just the amount of rejection that comes
with acting the amount of like wedging
yourself into these roles that are other
people it's like no i deserve to be
myself man like it's been enough enough
of being other people enough of spending
my life trying to be who my mom wants me
to be in producers and record labels and
like i'm done and i think walking away
from that well i mean it was certainly
the hardest thing everybody in my family
is going don't walk away from this you'd
be insane to walk away from this you
can't why would you do that do you know
how hard it is to be successful at
acting what are you thinking and i was
like i don't know i feel like i have to
do it and and it was really hard but it
was me kind of taking a stand for myself
and i'm really glad that i did it